over 100 million Americans are
experiencing some of the worst air
quality ever recorded as smoke from
wildfires in America's Top Hat makes its
way South the scenes from New York City
are downright Eerie a Broadway performer
walked off stage during a matinee
yesterday because she couldn't breathe
it is genuinely scary for people and you
know what that means means it's the
perfect opportunity for liberals to push
their fear-mongering climate change
agenda the smoke had just barely
appeared in the sky when Randy
Weingarten the nation's teacher Union
boss and Democrat Party operative but I
repeat myself she blamed the Smoke On
You Guessed It climate change Weingarten
tweeted climate change is real please be
careful today in NYC
but winegarden a well-known private jet
Enthusiast neglected to mention how the
wildfires in Canada are connected to
global warming or global cooling or
climate change or whatever and the
reason for that Omission one suspects is
that there is no discernible connection
at all
the wildfires in Canada have burned 9
million acres of land pretty bad
but is it historically bad
no
9 million acres is a lot
but nine million acres is nothing
compared to the 49 million Acres that
burned 20 years ago during the Russian
wildfires of 2003.
still 2003 relatively recent maybe that
was climate change too well what about
the 1987 black dragon fire also in China
which burned 18 million Acres twice the
Canadian burn that turned New York City
orange were the 1987 Chinese fires
caused by climate change
maybe I guess the lips have been
shrieking about some sort of
environmental catastrophe since the 70s
how about the Siberian wildfires of 1915
which burned a whopping 35 million acres
of land in Russia
was climate change already in full swing
by 1915
industrialization started in Russia in
the late 19th century
so
Maybe
would have had to act awful quick to
blame industry for that one how about
the black Thursday bushfires of 1851 in
Australia which burned 12 million Acres
33 percent more land than the amount
that has sent this historic plume to
America from Canada
how about the half million Acres that
burned every single year in Oregon and
Washington State alone since time
immemorial
prehistory
before a European ever set foot on that
land
were those climate change too
even a cursory glance at history shows
that lots of North America just like the
rest of the world has been regularly set
Ablaze long before any of the supposed
causes of climate change ever had any
effect or even existed
but a photograph and some liberal
demagogues with an agenda say that
wildfires are caused by your pickup
truck and your air conditioning
they're choosing to exploit a natural
crisis for their political purposes
they're confident enough that you were
never taught any of that history they're
confident because they control the
education system and the media
and the big Tech platforms on which
you're seeing all those scary pictures
right now go to expressvpn.com Knowles
did you notice the big tech companies
today are masquerading as privacy
companies just fix your privacy settings
turn off app tracking and you're all
good yeah right are we supposed to
believe that the big Tech wolf has now
turned into our sweet little Grandma I
don't think so big Tech feeds on your
information by collecting and selling
off your data they can't stop themselves
from looking at what you do online so to
protect myself against big Tech's prying
eyes I have chosen to use expressvpn
when you use the expressvpn app on your
computer or phone you are hiding your
unique IP address websites can't use
that address to find out your real
location or track what you do online
on top of that expressvpn encrypts and
rereads 100 of your online activity so
your internet provider Wi-Fi admin and
hackers can't see it
the best part though is how easy it is
to use I'm a lot eye not the biggest
Tech Guy you just click one button it'll
protect all your devices or boom click
it on your phone on your laptop you're
good to go one expressvpn subscription
covers up to five devices at the same
time so you can protect your whole
family too use the VPN that I trust go
to expressvpn.com Knowles get three
extra months for free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles to learn more right now go to
cinch.com use code nulls picture the
perfect Summer Night the warm breeze on
your face as you Lounge in your favorite
chair outside the grill sizzling with
Juicy delicious burgers the aroma of the
food is irresistible
now imagine what this perfect summer
night would look like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
we're empty
well that's where our friends at cinch
come in cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go to cinch.com or download the
Cinch app to order new customers can get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code Knolls cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls to get your first tank exchange
for just 10 bucks it's a limited time
offer you must live within a cinched
service area to redeem it cinch.com
offer for details the worst air quality
ever recorded in New York City
if you look at the pictures it's it's
bright orange there it's weird it's
crazy and hazy the wildest reaction to
this came from some yuppies yesterday at
equinox
The Equinox is a fancy gem for rich
urbanites
and and the picture was taken and
published I think by the New York Times
but it was taken of this rooftop of some
building in New York
where amid all the haze the dangerous
air quality there are a bunch of wealthy
young New Yorkers
standing doing some kind of yoga
salutation standing up arms in the air
like a religious worship ceremony
which is exactly what yoga is if you
were an anthropologist you were an
historian and you came across this
picture
500 years into the future you would say
oh this is an example of religion in
2023 New York this is an example of the
kind of public worship
that that existed in Liberal America in
and a modern person right now would say
no that's not true they're just doing
yoga you don't understand man that but
the thing is the historian would be
right this is an example of religious
practice all these little Millennial
yogis who instead of going to church
they go to yoga and they go to brunch
that is a religious practice
they're they're risking something about
their physical health here
which is the air quality they're risking
that because of something more important
which is what it's the religion of
self-actualization it's the religion of
of being at one with the universe man
it's the religion of looking around and
seeing the big vast beautiful view from
the very very top of the tower it's the
religion of self the religion of do
whatever you want the religion of take a
moment and relax from your busy work
schedule it's
a religious practice yoga is an actual
Eastern
religious practice that's why there's so
much spirituality associated with it and
a lot of westerners pretend they can
divorce those things but you can't
whatever you do
a lot whatever you do habitually is
going to have some tie in to religion
and in the case of yoga just happens to
be much more directly
spiritual
previously during a natural disaster or
some kind of Crisis you'd go in you'd
pray that's what Christians would do
you I don't know maybe you go to church
or something but that is that is the
church in New York and they're not going
to shut down
yoga Church during a natural crisis the
government might shut down your actual
Church they might shut down a synagogue
they might shut down maybe a mosque I
don't know if they would actually shut
down a mosque but they're not going to
shut down liberal Church
liberal Church being
the yoga studio and the brunch spot and
the pot dispensary they're never going
to shut those down boy what a great clip
that was make sure you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time